this week we've got moody robot big
butts out a huge Dookie now that's a
whole description of Geo right there
[ __ ] I should've listened to ivory
whenever your lips move I just
automatically tune you out so what were
they again TIFF thank God shut up damn
it I missed it
oh well everything to do with you moody
robot sex bot named Samantha they gave
that [ __ ] emotions yeah tell me you
love me give it to me daddy
that's the original programming but now
it's like please do you love me oh [ __ ]
me like you love me I'm not on my period
just being me you always use that for an
excuse she looks like Tyra Banks what
blue eyes heads are why hello when you
flip the computer around Sheila's hot
until I realized it was fake you know I
mean like that's how realistic was as
the computer oh she got too much plastic
surgery done yeah I wish it was a little
more natural looking and I don't like
the nails her fingers like [ __ ] weird
I look at a nail I think we talked about
her before when she first came out and
made headlines because of the first sex
robot that has an AI [ __ ] in jail well
yeah in jail yeah you [ __ ] a dude
nor would it I would thank you for being
honest show no shame it's like the first
day I get you'll get out you'll get out
tomorrow sorry you're here for a DUI I
can't wait I'm rich you know what the
sex robot reminds me of okay it reminds
me of aging hot girl yeah like in her
mid 40s that are doing that's doing a
lot of plastic surgery to stay young and
then that's what they look like yeah
that's you know like like she used to be
like a really hot like server girl at a
Vegas club and now she's like a cocktail
waitress that brings drinks to the bring
jinx to the you just wrote her whole
back casinos how do you know me so well
Jones made by this man here dr. Santos
how many times has he come dinner many
many many all right so he's married and
so his wife helps them oh she kinda
looks like his wife oh yeah so they work
together to create these sex robots and
she's she got the idea of putting an AI
inside of these robots don't do it don't
do it babe announced that she will soon
be able to pretty much reject having
intimacy with someone if they're just
not in the mood oh you have to get robot
consent yeah which is why do you think
it's the purpose of having a sex toy
yeah because so this couple what they
say is that what the [ __ ] do you believe
that this robot or like you know sex
robots can help marriages especially
when a married couple aren't really in
sync with their sex what that doesn't
make sense because then why would you
give that robot a choice cuz that your
wife's like I'm not down to [ __ ] when
you go to the robot I'm not either
[Laughter]
damnit
now you're forced to go to the
whorehouse or some [ __ ] no not really
because oh it won't it won't be like
that she's forced or whatever she could
go into a dummy mode which then like it
just certain switches off like her AI
capabilities and so if she feels that
she's being touched in an aggressive way
or a disrespectful way or if she's just
bored with the attentions of her
potential lover then she could just go
into dummy mode unplug her [ __ ]
batteries then that makes her rapey I'm
so you is it does it necrophilia if you
[ __ ] a sex robot after you take the
batteries up oh good question
cuz it's not a it's not what is one
people's obsession with artificial
intelligence like I don't understand
it's not not either option to be honest
yeah I don't understand the obsession
with it like a site I want to give this
person's sense of why boy what's the
purpose it's like they're intentionally
ignoring all of Hollywood warning y ou
upgraded this dope very limited release
but it was like surprisingly a lot
better than I was expecting I had no
expectations is amazing what's upgraded
it is in it you just gotta watch it
why don't you rather control a human
being than and then a robot cuz to me
controlling a robot is so wack
it's like so pretend but you're speaking
as an alpha person what about betas is
that what alphas - oh yeah an alpha
person thinks that they like what are
they really afraid of they can just say
what they gotta say make a robot of
confrontations but I wouldn't mind am I
better than cuz I like I wouldn't mind
having a robot to take my stuff to the
dry cleaners and then the dry cleaner
those would you like the one day wash or
the linen splash and the robot doesn't
have to text me but cuz [ __ ] AI can
figure that [ __ ] out my master would
like this no I mean like the but
wouldn't it be better if you had a
human-like secretary or someone to help
you know because there's the emotions
you gotta feed that [ __ ] you got
dogs [ __ ] [ __ ] what I mean
I mean so like in turn right yeah when I
get pissed out of Internet I can't just
pop
fool in the face I'm gonna get in
trouble also if you had a robot you
could slap him across the face yeah fun
like getting mad I can dish it out I'll
kick him in his robot nuts hmm
you know what I mean I mean everyone's
different
a what a [ __ ] a beta I don't know I
don't know what you're talking about
it's it's weird because it's like I
think like the thing that's kind of
funny for me is people want to have
these automated things to do regular
stuff so they could have free time to do
exactly you're [ __ ] dumb you're not
doing [ __ ] with your life anyways yeah I
mean so a lot of the people that could
be a problem which I find not useful I'm
talking about a lot of people who are
hyped about AI it's like you can't even
get like your normal [ __ ] done just
could you have more free time doesn't
mean that you're gonna get anything else
done you're just gonna sit around doing
nothing Walley world and I'm saying this
is a man who had a Tesla so like for me
to like even when I do Park on has a I
write a little bit I mean but like even
that to like I only use the autopilot
when I'm in traffic and a stop and go
stop and go but if it's an open road I'm
just gonna drive like it's not that much
work you know I always drive with my
peripheral vision what you know we're
not in a cell phone and you just kind of
feel where the bottom drive with myself
yo I heard in California that it's like
a pretty big offence to drive you know
just text and drive you know how before
it would just be like a ticket just
don't do it at all yeah it's supposed to
be pretty bad now though it's like
terrible like that a setup for a joke no
I'm I'm saying don't do that
oh I don't text and drive cuz I don't
have the skills to you know what they
should be focusing on I think all this a
I [ __ ] on a sex robot it's like they're
putting a lot of effort into something
that people don't need what people need
is a warm wet [ __ ] on the AI you have
all this technology on a sex toy right
yeah this is gonna be next level is
think about like it's still gonna be
like room temperature cold latex [ __ ]
right so you still got a [ __ ] well it
does my brain yeah that's cool but it's
still you gotta warm it up imagine if
that Malvika
had a heating pad like you know like
with these new cars you got you could
sit down and it warms your ass and [ __ ]
like that so imagine that but in the
sex robots titties and and and vagina
and then there's like little bits of
lubrication that slowly secrete yeah
that's the [ __ ] only Japanese people
can think like that yeah Japanese mind
that you need like I think it's just
like a gene that that Japanese people
have but that's why they make the best
robot exactly I'm giving him I'm giving
him thank you yeah that's why I'm like
you you're thinking of the wrong thing
you want a [ __ ] sex robot that says
no what the [ __ ] dude that's like
getting a vibrator that doesn't vibrate
yeah but dildo that has choices and [ __ ]
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] yeah like not
today I'm at a wanting can you imagine
if you bought a dildo right and then
like it is randomly gets lip and it's
like you know like it's like hard as
[ __ ] and you're like doing it and it
gets lip and a dildo goes sorry I don't
know what happened I'm not usually like
this it's just an off day I got a lot on
my mind a lot of lonely people would
probably get these dolls cuz they could
talk to them that's why it has the AI in
there so it's ad so a celebrity
dermatologist is now saying that big
butts are out a dermatologist what the
[ __ ] does he know yeah what does he do
that even a plastic surgeon yeah I was
like I'm a little confused
he's like by the study of the eczema he
does do like but organ augmentation
Dermatology's I guess I don't know
interesting there's a lot of his clients
like not looking for butts anymore what
do they want yes here reporting the
trenors he's setting the trend is he
saying no so he's just seeing that a lot
of people don't really care about butts
anymore yes okay i'ma tell you something
mr. dermatologist she's observing I'm my
own person
and I've been liking but since I was an
elementary school boy mm-hmm like I
guess gigantic but like never she has a
fake butt Kim no JLo JLo
well I mean they'd imagine
she is a client of his but I think that
dermatologist I mean it could be for the
reasons you just read but wow that's
like a basketball in her pants yeah
she's the one that I was like that down
she started her booty it's dope I know
look at that maybe she got a butt lift
then possibly but because that [ __ ]
looks a little - yeah
JLo what are you doing huh don't taint
your beautiful body you are a national
treasure
how does she - is that 40 something
right still 40 fibers in like that damn
yeah and they're like they're like have
I looked at pictures Jayla without mega
because I want to see what he ate
she's like all I do is drink water [ __ ]
so do eyes okay away from alcohol - yeah
well I only drink this you don't drink
water what's that red [ __ ] right there
yeah but I do so she doesn't mean she
doesn't drink other stuff Barts she does
and she told me all right water drinkers
don't drink other [ __ ] so what did they
what did this is a new trend
I like ass so the new trend here is ugly
stupid big lips yeah treating cleavage
lines what does that mean
so like wrinkles in your cleavage that's
a new thing all right like the
up-and-coming thing goes in your
cleavage
you know frequency micro-needling to get
rid of the wrinkles there and then
bringing the tip of the nose up and then
a drop of Botox oh like a Peter Pan nose
everybody began Botox on their [ __ ]
face man it's like a while dude come
here no what do you mean what you know
why I think it's because of the
Instagram culture because when all the
girls do get the Botox they look good in
the Instagram pictures but then when you
see in the real life you go watch enough
[ __ ] are you a doll yeah it doesn't look
right man I just want their faces can be
normal dude I like normal faces man
what's wrong with you man less face
that's so sad what people go through
where they're like I gotta change all
this [ __ ] about myself yeah I mean it's
not that I mean people have different
reasons - yeah it's not just like oh my
god I'm disgustingly ugly I need to
change it to me it's like this I don't
know it feels like people that do it
they start doing it on a consistent
basis and it's like what's
wrong with what you have that's in your
control you know I mean like you oh good
I was like I got my boo talked about
yeah yeah well you were flatus like the
people I want to lose weight that's like
there's a health function yeah right
like what's the health function to the
Botox or to the dislike there's like
it's just cosmetic and so there's an
insecurity that they have that they
can't get over that specific cause
necessarily uh so for for a percentage I
feel like yes they are insecurities for
other people I feel like they think
they're so fine but they just they're
like if I just tweak this one little
thing and be like the perfect there's no
such thing as perfect people or for them
for what they want their own standards I
think for because I have a friend who's
like doing that she did get plastic
screws she got her nose done
and she's like one of the most confident
people that I know and she was just like
yo I'm fly as [ __ ] but damn like I just
hate this thing like when I put on my
makeup or when I want my my my official
like when I'm done getting ready for
whatever like I just want it to be this
but also in five years
do you things are so temporary like
you're in five years your eyes are here
you know or like it whatever you so
whatever you've done it's gonna change
it's not it's not gonna last very long
like every two or three years like you
age and as you're aging your face is
shifting everything is moving yeah so
you constantly have to keep up with it
possibly who knows what you're gonna
look like in five years so I even adjust
yourself now if it's purely cosmetic I
want to see the between you to do that
in five but see that's one thing I want
to see the person who does it and then
they're satisfied and I don't think
they're ever satisfied you know what I
mean so it's this change then that
changed then this change then that
change this change is like it's
consistent you know what I mean so like
verbally you could say like oh I
completely love myself and I love the
way I look but you're always changing
your face because every time you look in
the mirror you see a flaw you know and I
like I'm not hating on it is what is
your [ __ ] face
I wouldn't classify everyone in that you
know I mean I think there are those
people not classified everything and I'm
not hitting on it but I also think like
the amount of scrutiny that people have
for the outside they don't share the
amount of scrutiny for the inside yes
yeah this is how discipline I am yeah
how where's my plastic surgeon for my
discipline my motivation my initiative
my responsibilities my priorities like
all the scrutiny is here when you can be
a better person instead of just looking
better - yeah yeah I know some famous
Instagram models where they got caught
with their plastic surgery and I'm like
damn good [ __ ] job because there was
no way in hell you would have been a hot
ass it's a grand model with a lot of
followers with the way that you used to
look but now good for you whatever teach
throne I like using like Courtney Cox as
an example it's Courtney Cox she got a
lot of like fillers and stuff then she
recently she's stopped doing all that
[ __ ] and she looks great again you know
I mean
so she says like she got I got tired of
this like this is this is dumb it's not
right
you know and then she went back to I was
like oh she looks great again because I
saw her picture and I was like whoa
little face she that's awesome what
happened she'd stop doing she's not on
menteng it because she said that she
kept on having to change stuff
constantly and it was never enough you
know I saw her say the same thing yeah I
mean for some people for sure it's like
I think I think for all people I don't I
don't really think it's like an
individual thing like Oh some people not
do it I think like for reals if you look
in the mirror all the time in your ease
you're always like condemning what you
look like every day that [ __ ] up your
head consistently moving on to the last
or eager so it's 57 year old man from
the melborne he went to the hospital
after he had extreme pain in his right
leg he had a swollen abdomen he was very
nauseous
he was absolutely constipated for the
last three days and it turns out that he
had a baby a lot of [ __ ] in there baby
Oh God
no I mean the next race how many pounds
did they find out so it was two liters
of poop two liters like a [ __ ] thing
no soda yeah they took out two liters oh
my [ __ ] holy [ __ ] wait is that up to his
lungs it is brain I don't know I really
can't make it I think that's all I care
that is ridiculous
he'll the bone area yeah that's like a
top-down view across [ __ ] holy this is 1
litre so it's two of these yeah yes a
soda that should have been though if it
came out of his butthole no they said
that if you would have waited longer
than you've died not here today they
would have caused multiple organ
failures because it was pushing
everything seeing everything can I see
the first [ __ ] picture the big man man
can't handle just 2 litres of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
pikas barely 2 liters right now imagine
tiger coming out of her [ __ ] right now
[Laughter]
this was true leaders I know but that's
flesh bones [ __ ] must this is just
[ __ ] squishy [ __ ] why did he keep eat
he's way more than my baby you got to
imagine we can ignore and you have to
imagine Tiger coming out your [ __ ]
not your [ __ ] no he had to have surgery
from this [ __ ] you had a c-section that
[ __ ] food section I'm so glad I'm not a
surgeon I'm so glad I'm not a surgeon
because if I was a surgeon if I was
deciding where to make the incision I'm
like the only natural thing is to cut
from the butt hole so I have this fool
thank god you're not a doctor
face stomach down and I'll cut from his
butt hole to his back he's fine because
I want to keep it as natural as you're
just gonna give him the longest ass
crack on earth
please asides until this poop comes out
forever
plumbers crack how did it get stuck
that's so gallant try anything like
laxatives or anything cuz maybe he did
but that looked like one big Dookie like
if you were to just take a dump and
magnify that [ __ ] it was still in the
shape of it like Dookie lump I bet you
he did that multi-body Harding [ __ ] you
guys do that [ __ ] what it came out nice
and smooth Wow Wow breaking it up they
don't really mention what happened
exactly it's just that he has bowel
issues and that he actually spent 23
days in the hospital for this and that
now he needs to constantly use laxatives
to like get the rest of them damn that
sucks yes it doesn't say like what
triggered it though I don't know stress
even like a normal like healthy diet
like vegetables that's not gonna help of
like high waters no he just needs shabu
shabu it was published in the British
Medical Journal he feels great though
now huh I bet you he's in the Guinness
World Records for a [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
see I told you [ __ ]
you were always full of [ __ ] he's
actually spent four days in the ICU oh
[ __ ] you guys think you gonna that much
[ __ ] and it's all the way up here that
when he's talking his breath smells like
[ __ ] too it just smells like Dookie
breath like this real Dookie he burps in
this part Oh bro your breath smells like
that sometimes
[Laughter]
[Music]